[Music]
hey Bill letting in and I'm a computer
science student so the fields of machine
learning and robotics has making
technological advances and replacing
human labor at a blinding speed and at
this point it seems almost inevitable
that virtually all jobs are going to be
automated in the future so my question
is this when and if machines replace our
jobs
what should we spend our lives
accomplishing instead if it's some
greater goal that we should aim toward
thank you so much
machines are going to replace every job
what about this job right here man
what about that I'm thinking what about
that man
so I think they'll still be a great many
jobs that require human involvement
after all why have humans build machines
if there isn't something humans want to
do play baseball
or argue about what machines are going
to do so I claim that there's a lot of
jobs that we would all prefer machines
do like if I don't know if you've ever
made pancake batter mixing it by hand
it's okay cake batter mixing it's okay
but it's easier to do it with an
electric mixer I don't know if you've
got up every morning up every morning
and adjusted the thermostat in your
apartment or house and then when you
leave for work or school you turn it
back down and then when you come home
you turn it back up and then right
before you go to bed you turn it back
down I don't know if you've done all
that but automating that seems to me
cool and nice I don't know how much
welding you've done of auto bodies it's
it's a cool skill to develop but it's
not one that really we all are going to
need in the future my grandfather went
into World War one on a horse he was
apparently skilled enough horseback
rider to live through it it's not a
skill that most I'll I grew up driving a
stick shift in a car I can drive a stick
shift it's not a skill you need anymore
it's very seldom so it's okay man as
jobs become automated humans will go do
what humans want to do come up with new
machines come up with new ideas new
techniques and mathematics that will
simplify things even more make
discoveries of life on another world and
what I still love about movies and
television and computer videos it's
still handmade I still love that the
lights are put in by hand we make these
decisions about what questions to take
from you by hand or by brain and I still
love that so yes we want to automate the
world to the extent that is comfortable
but
more we can do this man it's gonna be
great you go to the airport you get on
the train between terminals you trust
that it's going to drive you from one
place to another without crashing
because engineers have been very
diligent setting it up make train
figures out how many too much people
weigh and their luggage provides the
right amount of electricity to
accelerate and decelerate the Train and
we trust that that's good that doesn't
mean we're not going to want to travel
it's good it's a good question now
carry on man
[Music]